Hey there. As always, a warm welcome
from wherever and whenever you might be
tuning in from, especially if this is
your first time with us, Adventist or
otherwise. So, if there's one thing the
SDA church is obsessed with, it is
Satan. Whether it be his satanic majesty
or his thoughts, him holding a secret
council meeting in outer space to figure
out how to attack Seventh Day Adventus
and the Sabbath, or his supposed false
repentance prior to his banishment from
heaven. I never heard more about Satan
than when I was an Adventist. Which is
why I wanted to invite my friend Dr.
Josh Howard to join us and discuss the
subject of Satan. Particularly though
with regards to what the scriptures have
to say about his fall and defeat in
light of the SDA church's very elaborate
extra-blar. Josh Howard serves as an
elder and pastor at Grace Community
Church in Battle Creek, Michigan. He's
an alumni of Midwestern Baptist
Theological Seminary, Mid America
Baptist Theological Seminary, and
Northern Arizona University with his
doctoral dissertation on the subject of
Satan's defeat. He's published several
books and articles, including stories
about the end of things, served as an
adjunct professor, and is the general
editor with Esquetology Matters. So,
does the Bible teach that Satan was ever
next in honor to Jesus Christ? That he
became jealous of Jesus being exalted,
leading to a great controversy? When and
where was Satan defeated and what does
that look like? All of this and more
coming up next. But quickly, I want to
remind you that if you like what we're
doing here, you can support us by
joining our membersonly section by
clicking that little join button down
below this video or by visiting our
channel homepage where you'll find the
same one. For about a coffee a month,
you can join our growing crew, engage in
our workshop style live streams, and
access our whole library of membersonly
content. It's your support that enables
us to fulfill our mission to equip as
many Christians as possible to reach as
many SDAs as possible with the true
Christ and his
gospel. All right. Well, Josh, thank you
for being here. We're in the reversed
roles now, so I'm looking forward to
hearing you talk more than me this last
time. Uh, how are you doing today? I'm
doing well, man. It's great to be back
with you and yeah, appreciate the
content you've had coming out. Yeah,
thank you. Uh, you're actually located,
so a lot of people in our audience will
know exactly where this is, but you're
actually located in Battle Creek, which
is an epicenter of Adventism. Do you
have many interactions with Adventists
at all? Uh, not exactly. Um, you know,
we we we know a few a few folks around
town, but you can definitely see there
there's a lot of SDA churches in the
area. There's the old u uh historical
center downtown where they've got the
what is it, the bunk houses or whatever.
They used to have a you know center
center down there that they've uh since
abandoned and and turned into a
historical site. But um we have noticed
a lot of a lot of Seventh Day churches
that aren't Adventists. So a lot of
Seventh Day Baptist, Seventh Day
Pentecostal, a lot of lot of those that
were unfamiliar to us. But well, that'd
be a conversation for another day, but
it'd be fun to discuss kind of their
thoughts around other uh Seventh Day
Sabotarians. Um absolutely. But yeah,
another another uh discussion for
another day. We're going to talk about a
subject that's rather expansive when it
comes to well really just Christian
theology in general, but uh especially
SDA theology. This is to say the
foundation for the SDA church's
worldview comes from an extra biblical
pre-earth origin story called the great
controversy. The fuller name being the
great controversy between Christ and his
angels and Satan and his angels. This
paradigm is supposed to give answers
that scripture is not exhaustive on. So
when you told me that a theological area
of expertise for you was the defeat of
Satan, I thought you would be the
perfect guest to have on to discuss some
of the great controversy worldview in
light of scripture and see if we can
maybe pinpoint some of the specifics
around where things go beyond scripture
in this system. Sound good? That sounds
that sounds great. Yeah, absolutely.
Perfect. So let's start here. This is
what the SDA church teaches regarding
the fall of Satan. So in Ellen White's
The Spirit of Prophecy Volume 1, she
starts by saying, "Satan in heaven
before his rebellion was a high and
exalted angel next in honor to God's
dear son. His countenance, like those of
the other angels, was mild and
expressive of happiness. His forehead
was high and broad, showing a powerful
intellect. His form was perfect, his
bearing noble and majestic. A special
light beamed in his countenance and
shone around him brighter and more
beautiful than any of the other angels.
Yet Jesus, God's dear son, had the
preeminence over all of the angelic
host. He was one with the father before
the angels were created. Satan was
envious of Christ and gradually assumed
command which devolved on Christ alone.
So she claims that before his fall,
Satan was next in honor to Christ, but
was envious of him and gradually began
to assume command that devolved onto
Christ alone. We will look at this
development of authority in a moment.
But Josh, does the Bible teach anywhere
or allude to the idea that before his
fall, Satan was next in honor to Jesus?
So yeah, the easy answer is no. um an
emphatic no. But um one of the things
that that uh well it might help just to
explain how I got into to studying Satan
because that's kind of a weird uh a
weird thing to be studying. But
initially I was looking at kind of that
Chris victor theme of scripture, Christ
as victor, Christ as the victorious
conquering one. And so that was kind of
the theme I was looking at through
scripture. And when you do that you
inevitably have to deal with, you know,
what is Christ victorious over? Um, so
he's over, you know, he's victorious
over sin and death and hell, um, over
all the forces of evil, but he's also
victorious over Satan, um, as a
character in that biblical story. So,
Satan comes into the picture, but he
only comes in tangentially, I would say.
Um, so one of the one of the things
about studying uh, anything that
scripture has to say about Satan. Um,
and I limited most of my study to what
scripture had to say as opposed to say
extra biblical material. Um, there
there's lots to be found as you've just
read um, from other sources. But when
you looked at what scripture actually
confesses about Satan, there's not a
lot. And that's one of the things that I
think gives people a lot of room for
speculation and um a little bit of of
imagination when it comes to those type
of things because typically Satan is
just sort of referred to in passing. So
um I'm sure we'll get into some of the
passages that speak about that, but as
far as who Satan is and if if there's
any credence to what you just read from
from Ellen White, um none of that is
found in scripture. What what we do know
for sure about Satan is that he is a
created being. Um he is a created being
who is lesser than the creator. He's
he's there's the creator creature
distinction that's that's very clear
throughout scripture. Christ is above
all all created powers including the
angelic beings. You find that especially
in like Colossians 1 or Ephesians 1. A
lot of the stuff that you were covering
at the beginning I I find just not
supported by scripture. So, you know,
you're referring to his countenance or
or his forehead, which I'm sure there's
there's much for you to say and and to
uh to explain with those comments. Um,
but that stuff's just simply not within
the biblical narrative. Um, what is
clear within the biblical narrative is
that Satan is he's evil. He's real. Um,
he's a defeated enemy and he's also a
created being. And I think that really
strikes at the heart of what you were
getting at there from that quotation is
that he is not in any way to be compared
to Christ. And it's one of the strange
things when you look to a lot of I would
say offshoots, but any offshoots of
Christianity, including things that are
clearly cultish or heretical with any
one of those given movements, um you
often times see a whole lot of a whole
lot of explanation about Satan that is
just simply extra biblical um sources.
It's stuff that scripture does not
support and often things that scripture
contradicts. Yeah. The idea of um so
they're obviously going to say that
Satan was never above Christ. Um, and
they're going to also try and say Christ
is the creator of Satan, but uh, think
of it like Satan being the highest of
all the created beings. He was the
closest that you could come as a created
being to God himself. But then the whole
narrative is kind of positioned as this
sort of back and forth sort of like
dualistic type thinking where good and
evil are waring back and forth and you
as a as a human being are caught in this
great controversy between Christ and his
angels and Satan and his angels as if
there's really any sort of uh shared
ground in that sort of capacity. But
then she continues and explains this
further where she says, "The great
creator assembled the heavenly host that
he might in the presence of all the
angels confer special honor upon his
son. The son was seated on the throne
with the father and the heavenly throne
of holy angels was gathered around them.
The father then made known that it was
ordained by himself that Christ his son
should be equal with himself, so that
wherever was the presence of his son, it
was as his own presence. The word of the
son was to be obeyed as readily as the
word of the father. His son he had
invested with authority to command the
heavenly host. Especially was his son to
work in union with himself in the
anticipated creation of the earth and
every living thing that should exist
upon the earth. His son would carry out
his will and his purposes, but would do
nothing of himself alone. The father's
will would be fulfilled in him. So God
the father called the heavenly host
together to let them know that he had
ordained that Christ should be equal
with himself such that when Christ gives
a command it was to be seen as though
the father was giving that command. He
was invested with this authority from
the father to be the head of the angels
in heaven and would also be involved in
the creation of the earth with the
father. This was the next paragraph
after the previous quote that we read.
So Josh, was Jesus exalted to be made
equal with the father at some point
prior to the creation of the earth?
Yeah. So what I fear that a lot of my
answers are going to be just like really
boring to your audience because again
the easy answer is just no. So, um, if
we were to look at if we were to look at
Orthodox Christianity, um, Caledonian
Christianity, uh, when when you're
looking at the persons of the Godhead,
um, you have to obviously we want to be
really careful with our language, but
you have to confess father, son, and
spirit, co-equal, co-eternal, co-en
co-in power. Um, often times we we'll
use very specific language um, to even
differentiate the the persons of the
trinity just to avoid any sort of any
sort of semblance of one being over or
against the other. Um, and that plays
into a lot of what we're talking about
here. The the only the only times you
get uh a reference in scripture about
Christ being made higher is specifically
in regards to his his economic work. So
Christ taking on flesh um the whole
mystery and and miracle of the
incarnation and Christ walking among us
on this earth. Um there was a sense in
which in his humanity he experienced
things but that's never at the sacrifice
of his deity. So when even when we talk
about him being uh above earthly powers,
a lot of this language has to do with
what he accomplished in creation, it's
not referring to what he has
accomplished as God or as creator. The
the the the things that you were just
reading and referring to. Obviously,
that's not in scripture anywhere. We
don't we don't find anywhere that talks
about some sort of pre-biblical, I guess
we could say, event um where Christ is
made higher than the other created
beings. What we can and must confess,
though, is that all things were made
through him and for him. um he is before
and above all things. That's precisely
because uh Christ to speak of Christ uh
prior to the creation or prior to the
fall even um is to speak of Christ as
God um as as co-eternal co-ine with the
father and the son inseparable and yet
distinct persons of the godhead. So
again the easy answer on this one is
just a simple no. Um and it would it
would run counter to Christian
orthodoxy. Caledonian Christianity is
what I referenced earlier but the creeds
and confessions have always confessed to
this sort of thing as well. Yeah, this
is why I'm always pressing on this
particular issue and I was curious to
hear your thoughts on this and people on
our platform tend to probably get tired
of hearing me harp on this, but uh it it
really showcases a fountain head element
here as you're going to see as we move
further along in this narrative that
really all of Seventh Day Adventist uh
theology centers around this whole
concept. This is kind of the first
domino, if you will, when the worldview
is titled the great controversy theme or
the great controversy worldview. Well,
what started this
controversy? That has to be a fountain
head statement. Well, it's this action
of the father exalting the son in some
pre-earth origin story. That is
technically the first domino that leads
to what she says now in response to
this. Satan was envious and jealous of
Jesus Christ. Yet when all the angels
vowed to Jesus to acknowledge his
supremacy and high authority and
rightful rule, Satan bowed with them.
But his heart was filled with envy and
hatred. Christ had been taken into the
special counsel of God in regard to his
plans. While Satan was unacquainted with
them, he did not understand, neither was
he permitted to know the purposes of
God. But Christ was acknowledged
sovereign of heaven. His power and
authority to be the same as that of God
himself. Satan thought that he was
himself a favorite in heaven among the
angels. He had been highly exalted. But
this did not call forth from him
gratitude and praise to his creator. He
aspired to the height of God himself. He
gloried in his loftiness. He knew that
he was honored by the angels. He had a
special mission to execute. He had been
near the great creator and the ceaseless
beams of glorious light in shrouding the
eternal God had shone especially upon
him. Satan thought how angels had obeyed
his command with pleasurable elacrity.
Were not his garments light and
beautiful? Why should Christ thus be
honored before him? So Christ the son
being made equal with the father and
given authority over all the angels in
heaven leads to Lucifer becoming jealous
of Christ. And that's the first domino
in this great controversy between Christ
and Satan. And it ultimately leads to
Satan falling from heaven. She says that
this led him to wonder why wasn't he
honored in the same way? Wasn't he
beautiful? After all, he'd been close to
God's throne um and the ceaseless beams
of light shining especially upon him.
But according to scripture, why did
Satan fall from heaven? Yeah. So, one of
the one of the one of the tricky bits
with this is is what we're looking at in
scripture when we talk about Satan and
and from that we work through what
passages are referring to Satan. Um, and
this is a matter of no small debate.
Whenever you talk about Satan within
scripture, um, part of the debate is
just settling on which passages are
actually referring to Satan, uh,
specifically as a as a as an entity, as
a being, as a spiritually created, um,
thing. There's there's several passages.
Um, I would point people to three in
general. There's there's three Old
Testament passages that really start to
set set the stage um, for who Satan is
and where he where he comes into being.
The New Testament speaks much more about
Satan, much u maybe more freely. Um but
the three places in the Old Testament I
would certainly point people to would be
um Genesis chapter 3. Uh that would be
one of those foundational stories. Um
it's set up as the serpent in the
garden. Um this is during the fall
narrative. Um, but we know from later
passages and specifically from the the
uh continued um the continued revelation
in the New Testament, we know from like
Revelation 12:9 very clearly alludes to
the serpent in the garden as Satan as
the um as the the same character. So, we
know that Genesis 3 is pointing to
Satan, but beyond that, it gets a lot a
lot more difficult. Um, Zechariah 3
refers to Satan walking in and accusing
the brethren before the throne of God.
uh Job 1 and two refers to Satan, you
know, strolling into the presence of God
and uh God, you know, speaking to him
and that that the whole setup to the the
Job saga, but it gets a lot more
difficult beyond that. Um there's a
couple of passages that when I was doing
my research on this, I referred to them
as as unclear passages. Um it doesn't
mean they don't refer to Satan, but it
does mean that that it's a lot less
clear and there's a lot more debate over
the words that are used. Um, and the
three that most people would probably
point to when they're thinking through
that question that you asked, which is
where what's the origin story of Satan?
Where did he come from? How did he fall?
Um, how did this whole thing begin? The
unclear passages would be Isaiah 14, uh,
specifically 14:12, and maybe you could
even look to Isaiah 27:1. Uh, there's a
reference in 1 Chronicles 21. Uh, so
that' be 1 Chronicles 21 really there in
verse 1. And then there's one in Ezekiel
28:14. That's typically where people
will draw from when they're trying to
think through why it was that Satan
fell. If you think back to those three
passages I referred to a minute ago,
none of those give any sort of
indication of any sort of pre-lapserian
or pre-mundane fall of Satan, whether it
was before the fall of man or whether it
was before the creation uh account,
whatever that looks like. Uh we're
simply not told from those accounts. You
look to Genesis chapter 3 and you're
told um there is a serpent that slithers
into the garden. He tempts Eve and then
subsequently Eve and Adam both eat of
the fruit. Adam uh because Adam ate of
the fruit, mankind fell with him. And
then we have the whole fall account. Um
following that fall account, you have
obviously the protege in Genesis 3:15
where we're told that God pronounces
judgment upon the serpent. Um he
commands that he will crawl in the dust
and he will eat the dirt and that he
will be on his belly the rest of his
days. Even that passage in Genesis
chapter 3, there's a lot of questions
there. Um you could get into is this is
this Satan personified? Is he crawling
as a serpent? um does he somehow go into
the form of a serpent or or we could say
take over a serpent? That was that was
the view of some of the reformers. I
think Calvin and Luther both held to
that view that it was a serpent that
Satan kind of used uh for his own
purposes. But in any case, all you have
is Satan enters the scene, he tempts um
and he brings destruction and he is
judged because of it. There's no there's
no telling of how he came onto the
scene. Um there's a little bit of
reference to the fact that he is crafty
and there's a little bit of word play
there that's really interesting. By the
way, when we're told that Satan was
crafty, there's a word play between the
craftiness of the serpent and the
nakedness of Adam and Eve. Um the word
play there is very similar. And you get
the same word play during the cursing
narrative. Um it's part of that ironic
judgment of God. But all you have is
Satan come onto the scene. We're told
he's crafty. We're told he's a created
being because again, serpent being a
created being. Then we're told he's
judged because of that. When you go to
the other two accounts, there's even
less kind of background information
that's given. Uh Job 1 and two, many
people are familiar with those passages.
We're just told Satan was wandering upon
the earth. So, we know he has access to
the created order. We know that he's,
you know, walking about on the earth in
whatever regards we can we can take
that, but there's no there's no
indication given as to how he came about
or what the fall looked like. And I
would say the same thing for Zechariah
chapter 3. We find him in this
accusatory position. He's accusing uh
the saints before the throne of God. Um
some have pointed to that. Um, I think
it was Ryan Stokes that's written quite
a bit on that that passage and talked
about the the prosecutotorial role of
Satan versus his acting as a judge or
even as a executioner of God. But
however you take that passage, there
there's no indication given as to how we
get there. So looking again to those
those unclear passages or we could say
less clear passages at least, uh, Isaiah
chapter 14 would be one of those that
people will look to and say that this
gives some sort of indication as to how
Satan felt. So Isaiah chapter 14 is
where we get the actual phrase Lucifer.
So the ph the term or title Lucifer many
many use it as a proper name of Satan.
Uh but it's really just the Latin
Vulgate uh its translation of this
phrase in Isaiah chapter 14 which is day
star. So if if we read that passage,
it's clearly referring to a figure there
in Isaiah's day. So there's a human
reference, but it's possible that it
could be referring to something beyond
just that human reference. Um there's
this dynamic that sometimes occurs
within the prophetic literature where
you have a prophetic perspective. Um
there's a near fulfillment and a future
fulfillment and something like that
could be going on here because if you
read the if you read the account there
in Isaiah chapter 14, it seems to be
pointing maybe beyond some some human
individual. But there's a lot in that
passage that's that's simply nonliteral
or not meant to be literal. There's
references to shale. We find that sort
of sort of reference all throughout the
Old Testament in nonliteral ways. Um at
least at least in some of the accounts.
So Isaiah 14 could be referring to
something something along those lines.
Um but it's simply not clear. But Isaiah
14 would be one thing that people would
look to and say this seems to be
indicating that Satan fell in some
regard. And it may even indicate some
sort of jealousy or some sort of some
sort of conflict with the other those
that were in heaven, whether it be
angelic beings or even with Christ
himself. Um that Satan would have some
sort of jealousy. But Isaiah 14, it's
certainly not clear in that regard.
Ezekiel 28 is much the same. Ezekiel 28
uses some pretty strong language. It's
obviously referring to a king of Ty.
There's a human reference that that
Ezekiel 28 is pointing to. And the whole
the whole passage there in Ezekiel 28,
the four words that are used there in
the latter part of of verse 14 or the
the beginning part of verse 14 are
pretty problematic. But it's got these
sort of these sort of descriptions there
in Ezekiel 28. We're told that the king
is to be the signate of perfection, full
of wisdom and perfect in beauty. That's
in 2812. Uh we're told that he had had
been in Eden in the garden of God.
That's 2813. He's described as an
anointed guardian cherub on the holy
mountain of God. That's
28:14. But yet he was one that was quote
proud because of your beauty unquote who
was subsequently cast to the ground. So
some people read through that reference
in Ezekiel 28 and say yes, it's
referring to a human reference there.
There there's a king. He he's an actual
man. This this is referring to something
then in Ezekiel's day, but this could be
speaking sort of broadly about this
satanic fall. So, it's speaking about a
human reference, but it also kind of has
in mind Satan. And and they'll go to
that because of the language used.
They'll say, "Look, this is clearly
referring to Eden. This is clearly
referring to some sort of fall. It's
pointing outside of just this guy. He
didn't walk in Eden. Therefore, it must
be referring to Satan as well." If you
were to just work through how to apply
that passage, though, the best you could
say is it's a veiled reference. This
isn't some sort of walkthrough of
satanic origins. Ezekiel doesn't set out
to give us a satanic origin story. What
he does do is communicates God's
judgment upon a human reference. And
there's a clear spiritual element
involved in that. So we could definitely
say that whatever human element is in
rebellion against God, in that way, he
is embodying the same rebellion, the
same sinfulness, the same evil as the
ultimate evil, as we could say a satanic
figure or as Satan himself. But it
certainly isn't giving us some sort of
detailed origin story. But Ezekiel 28,
Isaiah 14 would be two of the primary
places people would go to, especially
Ezekiel 28 and say because of the pride
reference and because of the beauty
reference, there's some sort of some
sort of prideful element involved there.
The other sort of disputed passage would
be 1st Chronicles 21:1. And there we're
told Satan stands against Israel. And
I'm not going to get too into depth on
this one, but I would say this one's
less clear than the first two. So Isaiah
and Ezekiel um both could have some sort
of veiled or prophetic reference to
Satan. uh 1st Chronicles 21 is a little
bit tougher. Um again, because Satan is
not the the the focus of the passage. So
in 1 Chronicles 21, we have this uh
executioner who comes against God's
people. Um it's it seems to be referring
to a heavenly being. But even that
reference of Satan, to a heavenly
heavenly creature, it has no definite
article that's used with it. It's just
the Satan. There's no there's no Satan,
which is the the Hebrew definite article
attached to the beginning. And what
makes the passage so difficult is it's
focusing on again the rebellion of
people and God's judgment against them.
So the focus of the passage is simply
not Satan, this angelic being. If it
indeed is is referring to Satan, he's
simply referred to in passing. So with
with all that kind of summarized, then
we're not given a whole lot of
information on any sort of origin story
for Satan. Um those passages in
scripture are are not even really
focusing on Satan. They're they're
usually focusing on a human reference,
which is what makes the interpretive
process a little bit more difficult. and
a little more painstaking in that
regard. So, you're highlighting um one
of the key things that I think is really
important to note and that's why so many
people are drawn to 7th Day Adventism
oftent times and it's because they have
and I feel like a lot of people have
this Adventist or not. They'll just find
the same sort of thing elsewhere. Um but
they have a bent toward like a Gnostic
idea of I want to have some extra
knowledge that the Bible doesn't give.
um that's going to give me some sort of
look behind the curtain, if you will.
And I feel like a lot of Adventists fall
prey to this because there's so many
things that you're saying there that
just in my head, obviously, I'm hearing
them and they think that they have this
extra insight that no one else has. And
it's really getting them to start
questioning that based assumption um and
bringing that then to the text because
all of the texts that you pointed to are
clearly the text that they they utilize.
Um, and I think it's important too that
you highlighted that they're some of
these passages are not as clear as
people may think that they are. Um, and
exactly what you said regarding Ezekiel
is typically um, right where they go to
kind of say the theme that's going on
there in the story that aligns with what
Ellen White is saying. She's just giving
extra details that God gave through her
to help us better uh, understand what
the text is saying. She's not adding to
the Bible. She's just giving a a
clarifier to something that's not that's
uh not as crystal clear or not as
obvious in the text, which is kind of a
subtle way of uh you know having a a a
lens over top of the Bible or an
authority over top of the Bible though
they'll want to tell you that no no
we're Bible only. But she Oh, go ahead.
No, I was just going to say I I I
totally agree with what you're saying
because one of the one of the I guess
frustrating things about studying these
things is if you go to like a local
bookshop or something and it doesn't,
you know, SDA out of the out of the
picture, any any sort of, you know,
purportedly Christian bookstore, um,
books on Satan and books on demons and
demonology, you know, replete with with
lots of detailed information that you
simply can't find within scripture. I I
I found that most of the most of to me
more of the compelling things that you
can tease out of scripture is some of
the word play that scripture uses. So
God's quite clever in the way he
inspired scripture to be written. And
when you look at some of the uh for for
example some of the etmological roots of
Satan that that that Hebrew phrase
Satanos um or Satan there in the the
Hebrew from which we get Satanos in the
Greek um it it seems to have some
Aramaic origins that would that would
couch the term of envy or despising. I
find that quite compelling because even
in the name, we might be able to tease
out a little bit of the character from
which this being uh has come. But but
it's it's hardly conclusive to build
some sort of origin story, but that
sells. Um it's it's a lot easier for me
to just write a book and say, "Listen, I
let me tell you let me tell you about
where Satan actually comes from versus
actually just dealing with the very
limited um information that we're given
in scripture, usually in passing because
we're being pointed to the victory of
Christ." Amen. Well, she goes on to say,
so the the narrative or the details
don't end there. She goes on to say that
Lucifer's rage couldn't be contained.
Um, the angels in heaven that that
remained loyal to God tried talking him
off the ledge, but he was too far gone.
Um, which led Satan to making
accusations against the Ten Commandments
and that God's government is not fair,
which is another core foundation to this
whole great controversy theme. So notice
she writes, "Satan grew bold in his
rebellion and expressed his contempt of
the creator's law, by which they mean
the ten commandments." That's what the
SDA church means. This Satan could not
bear. He claimed that angels needed no
law, but should be left free to follow
their own will, which would ever guide
them right. That law was a restriction
of the of their liberty, and that to
abolish law was one great object of his
standing as he did. The condition of the
angels he thought needed improvement.
Not so the mind of God who had made laws
and exalted them equal to himself. The
happiness of the angelic host consisted
in their perfect obedience to the law.
Each had his special work assigned him.
And until Satan rebelled, there had been
perfect order and harmonious action in
heaven. Then there was war in heaven. So
when they read that war broke out in
heaven in Revelation, it's these extra
behind the curtain details that they
will then plug into that and think that
that's what that is referring to. That
war broke out in heaven over Satan being
jealous of Jesus being exalted instead
of himself, which leads to him making
accusations against God and the Ten
Commandments. But more specifically, his
accusation included this as well. Christ
left his position in the heavenly courts
and came to this earth to live the life
of human beings. This sacrifice he made
in order to show that Satan's charge
against God is false. That it is
possible for man to obey the laws of
God's kingdom. So, it wasn't just a
general accusation against the Ten
Commandments, but specifically that they
can't be kept perfectly. And this is
actually why Jesus incarnated to silence
Satan's accusations in this controversy
and prove that man can keep the law
perfectly with God's help. So Josh, does
the Bible teach anywhere or allude to
the idea that Satan began attacking the
Ten Commandments in heaven and Jesus
incarnated to silence those accusations
and prove that they are wrong? Yeah. um
not biblically and and I would say of of
the questions you've asked so far, this
is one of the ones that uh that to me is
is one of the most problematic with some
really key doctrines um for Orthodox
Christian faith. So, one one of the
things that I would key in on there is
is in his role as accuser. So, so many
will will go to the name Satan and um
again, you can get into a little bit of
of deep water with this, but they'll
tease out the uh the accuser uh
reference out of his name. So there's
many names used to refer to to Satan. Um
just just looking at my quick list,
you've got he's referred to as the devil
or Diabolos. Be elible. He's referred to
the referred to as the strong one or the
evil one. Haponaras, we we catch that in
the Lord's Prayer. He's referred to as
the tempter, which is or also as prince
or ruler. And we can get into some of
those in a minute. But if you if you
just look to the reference as as Satan,
uh many have looked to his accusatory um
role. Um I I mentioned uh I think it was
Ryan Stokes earlier, which I I would
recommend caution with his work, but
he's done a lot of word studies at least
with the the titles and names that are
used for Satan. And you have to at least
admit even if there is some sort of um
prosecutorial role to Satan or some sort
of uh even as an executioner type role
to Satan, he's clearly an accuser of the
brethren. We know this from from
multiple references within scripture. So
if Satan has an accusatory role and we
look to then him accusing the brethren
about the Ten Commandments or accusing,
you know, making accusations about the
Ten Commandments or the the the keeping
of the law, um I think that that's where
people might be coming from with that.
But the reason I said this is this is
sort of chipping away at a key Christian
doctrine is that this chips away at what
Christ did in the atonement. So one of
the things that we celebrate as
Christians is that Christ has come not
only to pay our sin debt on behalf of
our breaking the law. Um a law which
Christ said is is itself right and good
but Christ has also come to completely
fulfill the law. So within Christian
orthodoxy we refer to this as the
passive and active obedience of Christ.
That he fulfilled the entire law um with
his perfect life and yet he also paid
the sin debt um on behalf of those who
have broken that law and who rightly
stand before God. So when we think to
the cross, what we celebrate as
Christians is that God's righteous and
just wrath must be poured out on lawb
breakakers. That God is in fact right to
uphold the law and he's also right to
judge those and to punish those who have
violated his good and perfect law.
That's what Christ has come to do on
behalf of his children. So to then throw
Satan into the mix here and say that his
coming and that Jesus incarnated to
silence those accusations and prove them
wrong. Um, this would be tantamount to
chipping away at why it was that Christ
came to fulfill the law on our behalf
and also uh to take the punishment for
the sin debt that we have incurred. Um,
the easy answer is that no, that's
that's found nowhere in scripture. But
the the more complex answer is that this
starts to chip away against some of the
key doctrines of the Christian faith in
regards to the atonement. Yeah. Well,
when you don't believe the atonement was
completed at the cross, um, because it's
all being filtered through this
paradigm, uh, it makes sense as to why
oftent times SDAs would not be able to
see why this is such a a crucial thing,
which is also why this is another thing
I'm constantly bringing up. Um, they are
on record stating that, uh, the great
controversy theme informs all areas of
of SDA theology. It also informs
specifically why Jesus came amidst a
list of a number of other things they've
listed out. And that's what it's
essentially being informed by. Um, and
that seems to be a very different
picture, like you said, than what
scripture puts forth. I haven't seen
anywhere where it states that Christ
came to silence accusations from Satan.
Really, the whole great controversy
paradigm revolves around God having to
vindicate his character against these
accusations. Right? It's also why the
law is such a central component in their
theology because if you disagree with
them, they will connect that as being a
an attack from Satan which started in
heaven. So when you tell them you're not
going to keep the law perfectly, you
guys don't keep the law perfectly. They
think they do. They'll say that they do.
They're the commandment keeping church.
We uphold all 10, not just nine of the
commands, uh is often times what they
say. And if you tell them um and explain
to them, I'm not disparaging obedience.
I'm not disparaging uh seeking a holy
life and holy living. Um but you're not
you you've already violated the law and
the law has no provisions for doovers.
Uh that tends to kind of fall in deaf
ears and it tends to oftenimes just be
met with well you're a tool of Satan in
this great controversy. And again it
brings us back to this paradigm that
really has to be questioned in order to
really uh see where the the problems
are. you can't just assume that
worldview um which is then going to
inform the the conclusions that you're
making. So I just say all that to say
these these sort of questions are being
informed by you know trying to help a
person see what the real root issue is
and that it's actually something coming
outside of scripture. Go ahead. Yeah.
No, that's that's good and helpful
because because like I said I don't I
don't interact apologetically with with
a lot of SDAs. One of the things I find
really troubling about this whole
scenario is at at the beginning of this
I I mentioned that when I did um my
initial research, you know, most of
this, you know, comes off my
dissertation research and a book that we
wrote following that. But when when we
looked at that stuff, one of the key
reasons that I excluded, uh extra
biblical literature, um was not because
those things are unimportant, right?
There's there's lots of fascinating uh
second temple Judaistic literature
that's come out that can help you at
least inform, you know, what were people
thinking at the time? what were some of
the common myths and common common
conceptions that are flying around at
that point. But one of the reasons why
we restricted um the the course of that
study was specifically because of the
weight of of revealed and inspired
scripture. So it was the place you know
not some sort of unhealthy biblatry or
anything like that but just to to hold
scripture on a different level as
theustas. This is God breathed and these
other things are just simply they're
simply not of the same account. So,
what's interesting to me in this
conversation is you have some things
like you've pointed out that are very
clear about what Christ came to do with
the law. Um, why the law is good and
what Christ has done to fulfill it and
who the actual law breakers are. Um, who
the lawgiver is and who is the rightful
judge of those who have broken his good
and perfect law. Those sort of dynamics
seem seem awfully clear. So it seems it
seems ironic that we're talking about
this in regards to Satan because one of
the clearest stories we know of Satan is
that he you know slithered into the
garden and asked ha has God really said
you know Adam and Eve being provided
with God's perfect revelation and yet
the initial biblically revealed action
of the serpent is to question what God
has revealed in his word. So, it's very
strange to me that we're relying so much
on holy extra biblical, if if we can at
least use that term, if not unbiblical,
but holy extra biblical revelation then
to explain what seems to be a pretty
clear narrative in scripture of what
Christ accomplished in the atonement.
Yeah. And and that Christ's active and
passive obedience are such an important
aspect in all of this. Um, again,
probably a discussion for another day.
They don't really understand the law
gospel distinction. Um, they really
think that the law is the gospel. So,
um, you know, Ellen White's on record,
for example, saying that, um, the law
points us to Christ who is standing
there with his wounded body. But because
that's being informed by why he came to
demonstrate the law can be kept, Christ
then points you back to the law when you
look at him because he's showing you,
look, you can keep the law. I have the
wounds to show it. The law is is able to
be kept, and I'm the the living
representation of that. So, he points
you back to the law, and with his help,
you're supposed to be able to keep the
law now. And so they're all kind of on
this hamster wheel, but really the fuel
for all of this is extra biblical. It
it's not coming from the biblical text.
Now, with all of that laid out, I know
that was a lot. I want us to actually
transition now to the actual defeat of
Satan and what scripture teaches
regarding this. I feel like that sort of
ground laying work that we just did
there is really important to understand
regarding the defeat of Satan to kind of
understand in the SDA zeitgeist that is
um where they're coming from. But
according to scripture, how, when, and
where was Satan defeated or has he not
been? And that is still a future event
to come. Yeah. Um, and this is one that
that that Christians frequently debate.
Um, if if you were to ask, you know,
most most Christians, is Satan defeated
now? I think most Christians would
probably look around and say, well, the
world looks very dark. There's evil.
There's there's injustice. there's
unbelief. There's all these things that
we would associate with the evil one. Uh
therefore, no, I don't think he is in
fact defeated. My my push back on that
has always been that when you encounter
scripture and and when you let scripture
speak for itself, which I know that's
that's what every Christian aims to do,
but I would argue that if we do that
with this category that we'll come away
with a different conclusion. Um, one of
the passages that that first uh I guess
keyed me in on this was uh John 12:31.
Jesus says, "Now is the judgment of this
world. Now will the ruler of this world
be cast down. Um, and that that word he
uses for the ruler is is a is an
interesting little phrase, but he says
now will the ruler, the archon is the
word in the Greek. Now will the ruler,
the prince, the false false prince of
this world be cast down. And he says it
was now. When you when you look at that
sort of dynamic there in John 12, it's
at this very fascinating sort of turn in
Jesus's ministry. You've got the the
leadup of that first half of John. Um,
the crowds are, you know, they love
Jesus. They love seeing the works that
he's doing. But Jesus starts becoming
more and more clear about what's
happening with his incarnation, what
he's come to do and what the cost is of
following him. You know, in other words,
Jesus is not just here to do tricks and
and provide bread, but um there's
actually much more to this whole thing.
And then that second half of John
essentially flowing from this passage,
you start to see a little bit of a turn.
You see you see the crowds start to go
away. You see the miracles ramping up.
They're getting bigger and bigger. Jesus
is is casting out demons. He's raising
men from the dead. Um, and yet the
crowds are getting smaller and the
opposition is getting more more
antagonistic, more amped up. Um, this is
right at that turn of which Jesus is
explaining to his disciples what it was
he came to do. And he says that part of
his work is a casting out of of the
ruler of this world. That that word cast
out um in the Greek there in John 12.
Same word that we find in Revelation 20.
And I don't want to open up that whole
that whole discussion necessarily, but
it's the same word. He is cast out,
Ekbalo, thrown out of this world. So
then you look to some of the other
gospel accounts. Um, one of my other uh
my other favorites is Luke chapter 10.
Um, in Luke chapter 10, Jesus is
commissioning his disciples. He's
sending them out two by two. They come
back and they're reporting, you know,
mighty works done in his name. They said
even, you know, even the demons um are
beholden to what we're doing. And Jesus
says, I saw, or you could read it as, I
am seeing Satan fall like lightning from
heaven. Now, now again, many Christians
when they read this, they say, "Well, if
Jesus saw Satan fall like lightning from
heaven, that must have been at some time
in the past. He must be maybe reflecting
on some some sort of, you know, past
event wherein he exercised Satan or cast
him down from heaven." But that's not
what Jesus says. He says in the context
of his disciples coming back, he says,
"This is what I am seeing right now is
Satan being Satan falling like lightning
from heaven." I if you continue looking
through the gospels and and again, I'm
not trying to pit Jesus's words versus
the rest of scripture. All scripture is
God breathed. theustas. But if you
listen to Jesus give his own account of
how it is that he is accomplishing this
victory in this world, one of the ways
that he describes it as him having bound
a strong man. Um this this this account
occurs as the strong man uh passage or
the beelible controversy is what it's
sometimes referred to. But you find this
in all three of the synoptic gospels.
And Jesus says that in his coming to
this world that he has bound the word
there being deo. He has bound up the
strong man. the strong man representing
Satan, he says, "I've I've come into his
house and I've I've bound him and
restrained him that I might plunder the
house. I've come for this house and the
things that are in it. Um, therefore, I
have restrained and tied up this strong
man that I might plunder his house." So,
when you look to what Jesus describes
his coming as having done, it's very
clear. He says, "I have bound Satan that
he might not uh do as he did." And I
can't remember if that was one of the
questions you were going to reference
later is what the binding of Satan
actually accomplished. So bring me back
to that if if if that's not on the
question list cuz I want to I want to
make sure to to address that. But Jesus
says that he came to defeat that strong
man. Now the tricky little bit comes
down to when exactly did that happen. Um
I think it's very clear that he did that
in his first coming. Uh in Christ's
incarnation um between his his
incarnation and the ascension at some
point in there Christ is binding the
strong man and defeating him. But the
question sometimes it becomes when
exactly did that happen? Did it happen
at the cross? Was it in the hour of his
death on the cross that he actually
accomplished this defeat of Satan? Was
it uh was it in his resurrection? Many
would point to his resurrection or maybe
even his ascension into heaven and say
this is that sort of key defining moment
in which Christ defeated Satan. I'm a
little I'm a little cautious on that
just because I don't think scripture is
abundantly clear. Um many times in those
passages, specifically with John chapter
12, it's pointing to the cross and to
the work he accomplishes on the cross.
But if you're fair with the gospel
accounts, the cross is rarely referenced
without sort of a view of what is to
come. In other words, it's not a cross
for the cross's sake. It's the cross
with the view of his resurrection and
ultimately his ascension in view. It's
hard to separate those events, I would
say, in the gospel accounts. So, usually
if I'm asked, I I would just say some
somewhere in that time of his death,
burial, resurrection, and ascension,
Christ accomplished that defeat of the
strong man. You are exactly correct. We
are going to come back to the binding of
Satan a little bit later, but I want to
lean into the centrality of the cross in
this context. SDA scholars and
theologians love to tout that the cross
is central to their paradigm. They're
they're always going to say, "No, no,
the cross is central. The cross is
central." They agree that Satan was
defeated there in some capacity or
another. However, this is of course
filtered through the great controversy
worldview. Another way of stating their
view would be that Satan's accusations
against God's law were silenced at
Calvary, where it was shown that God's
law is immutable and cannot change,
which was part of this pre-earth
accusation, which vindicated the law
before the world. So, the cross wasn't
necessarily about Christ coming to
fulfill the law. It was coming to
demonstrate that you can keep the law.
That's the sort of framework that
they're starting from. But notice what
Ellen White says regarding what happened
at the cross. She writes, "The blood of
Christ, while it was to release the
repentant sinner from the condemnation
of the law, was not to cancel the
sin. It would stand on record in the
sanctuary until the final atonement." So
in the type, the blood of the sin
offering removed the sin from the
penitent, but it rested in the sanctuary
until the day of atonement. So the cross
in Adventism was only where the atoning
sacrifice took place, not where
atonement was completed and Satan was
functionally what you would say bound.
No sins were actually canceled there.
The cross functions more like a conduit
in their system. It was the means by
which the earthly priesthood was
transferred to a heavenly sanctuary
building where Jesus would begin dealing
with sin in heaven. That's what they
mean by the final atonement. Right now
there's this starting in 1844 to the
present day that's the antityypical day
of atonement. This long drawn out period
where Christ is conducting the
investigative judgment. And this is
because their model of atonement is a
sevenstep program that they call the
sanctuary. Jesus is currently at step
five. And it's only after the completion
of all seven steps that Satan's defeat
will truly come. So my question for you,
in what way was Satan defeated at
Calvary and what actually took place
there?
Yeah. Yeah. That's that's really it's
heartbreaking what you just laid out.
Honestly, um I'm just thinking to
Colossians 1, Hebrews 1, um these
passages that speak about Christ above
all earthly authority and power, having
accomplished, not not accomplishing, but
having accomplished something in his
blood. So I'm saddened to hear that that
sort of synopsis. you just gave. Um, but
your question was to what what Satan has
been bound from. Um, and that's that's
one of the ones that again I mentioned
that this is not universally agreed upon
by Christians. Many Christians struggle
to to speak of Satan having been
defeated or bound. Um, and and honestly,
I think a lot of Christians would
probably be sympathetic to the viewpoint
of Satan having begun to have been bound
because that sounds a little better.
When we look at the world around us and
we see uh we see evil and we see sin at
work, it's easier for us to think of
something having begun. Um but I would
say that's impossible to square with
what scripture uh confesses about these
things. So anyway, you asked you asked
what is it that Satan has been bound
from. So uh number one I would say that
it is clear that he has been bound. When
Christ describes the binding of the
strong man, he doesn't say he has begun
binding him. Um he says that he has been
bound. Um, when we get to Revelation 20,
which is always the uh the passage that
uh that every esquetology likes to fight
over, uh, Revelation 20 describes uh, I
think most are agreed on some sort of
unbinding of Satan. And it's in the
unbinding of Satan that I think we can
get a lot of insight into what it
exactly is that he's been bound from.
When we look back to the biblical
evidence and we see especially in the
Old Testament prior in you know in
history and time to Christ's earthly
ministry uh we read about Satan roaming
freely upon the earth. We we read about
him roaming right into it seems into the
very presence of God and to his angels.
We see him making accusation against the
brethren. We see all those things pretty
clearly in the old uh Old Testament.
Christ comes, he accomplishes his
earthly work and we're told Satan is
restrained. So the whole question is
then from what? Um I think the three
things that scripture lays out for us
about his about his binding is that the
first thing is he's not uh he's bound
that he might not deceive the nations.
Um again it helps if we go to the uh to
the outworking of his unbinding to
understand what it is he's bound from.
And when we read Revelation 20:es
1-h or or uh and again trying to trying
to reflect on those very very uh very
broadly so as not to isolate any sort of
esquetologies but that unbinding of
Satan leads to an immediate deception of
the nations. Satan goes out and deceives
the nations and seems free to do so. So
if you're to look around right now and
say well it seems like the nations are
deceived. Um I I would encourage you to
reflect on what happens when the nations
are truly deceived. uh when the nations
are truly deceived, it leads to revolt.
And that would be the second thing that
I would say Satan is restrained from
doing. When when Satan is freed to truly
esqueologically deceive the nations, he
deceives them unto revolt. This
deception is not just simply a blindness
to the gospel. Um uh many places in
scripture, we're assured that uh our own
sinful nature does plenty to uh to blind
us to the truth of the gospel, lest God
gives gives us eyes to see or heart
heart to understand or ears to hear. Uh
but when Satan deceives, it's unto
destruction. So when Satan is released,
um the nations are deceived and they
immediately revolt against the king. Uh
but the third thing I would say he's
he's restrained from doing is preventing
the spread of the gospel. So when Satan
is bound, um if we if we think of that
Luke 10 passage, I think that might be
uh might be illustrative. Satan is
falling from heaven like lightning and
Christ says, "I am seeing Satan fall
from heaven like lightning." And that's
given in direct response to the gospel
mission of the disciples. The disciples
are commissioned two by two. They're
sent out into the cities. Um they're
told to cast out demons. They're told to
spread the gospel message. Um they're
seeing souls converted. They're seeing
the enemy trounced. And in that context,
Christ says, "Yes, I'm seeing Satan fall
like lightning from heaven." So, I would
say the three things that Satan is
prevented from doing is deceiving the
nations, leading those nations unto a
revolt that will end in their demise,
but then thirdly, preventing the spread
of the gospel message. You get another
hint of this. Well, it's not exactly
hint. You get another uh evidence of
this in the great commission. So in
Matthew 28 when Christ is assuring his
disciples of his ongoing presence with
them through the power of the holy
spirit through the helper that is to
come. He said all authority in heaven
and on earth is given to me. Go
therefore and make disciples of all the
nations uh baptizing them in the name of
the father and the son and the holy
spirit teaching them to observe all that
I have commanded you. So Christ in the
great commission passage itself tells us
that all authority heaven and on earth
has been given esquetologically to the
incarnate son. He holds that authority.
In other words, whatever authority Satan
wielded in this world uh under God's
permissive decree in the Old Testament,
he no longer has. And in that regard, we
are then as his disciples called to go
out and make disciples of the nations.
That's great stuff, Josh. Um, with all
that in mind, because what you said
there was was just e excellent. Uh, I
think that oftentimes, and I think
esquetology can kind of just be this way
in general, it's very easy to go off
into a lot of speculation or a lot of
reading into things because oftentimes
we're dealing with apocalyptic
literature or we're dealing with images
and pictures, etc. But with what you
just said in mind, I want us to look at
a clip now of an SDA pastor by the name
of Dwayne Lemon. And listen to what he
says regarding the crushing of
Satan. Go ahead and introduce a thought.
You you're going to see me magnify this
more and more as we spend time together.
But you know, as I told you last night,
there's a great work that God wants to
do. This is really the whole of the
gospel. The great work that God wants to
do is he wants to separate sin from the
sinner. And it's a very great work. But
go at the same time, God requires yours
and my cooperation. That's the only
reason why it's a difficult work even
for God because it requires more than
God. It requires us to cooperate with
him. And so it is that we learned
yesterday that God has a beautiful plan.
He's going to crush the head of that
serpent, but it's going to require our
cooperation, our submission. And
therefore, we saw that God has a
beautiful everlasting gospel principle
that was right there in the beginning of
time, Genesis chapter 3, where God
promised, I'm going to put hatred in the
heart of my people towards sin and
towards Satan. And though this might
feel like a miracle to many of us
because some of us have been bound for
many many years, most of our lives, I am
very grateful that Luke 18 and verse 27
says that which is impossible with man
is possible with God. And so no matter
how much even the devil has convinced us
that we could never overcome our bad
habits and overcome our sinful ways, the
Bible declares that whom the son sets
free will be free
indeed. All right. So notice there is a
lot that we could unpack there, but he
says there is a great work that God
wants to do in crushing the head of the
serpent. But to do it, he needs our
cooperation. And like we saw earlier,
he's getting at the idea that Satan made
accusations in heaven before earth that
the Ten Commandments can't be kept and
that the law must be changed. Jesus
silenced that at the cross by showing a
fallen person can do so because he took
on fallen flesh, they claim. And the
death of Christ showed that the law is
unalterable. But to truly crush the head
of Satan, God needs you to come to him
by faith to be empowered to do like
Jesus and keep the law perfectly, this
will lead to the ultimate crushing of
Satan. Dwayne Lemon even saying that
this is a difficult work even for God.
So Josh, is God's crushing defeat of
Satan dependent upon man cooperating
with him?
Miles, how do I respond to that clip?
There's so much there. to talk about.
So, one one of the things with with any
untruth there there's usually an element
of truth to it. Uh, you know, it's never
the direct the direct untruth that we
find appealing. It's always that that
truth that has a or that untruth that
has a shred of the truth in it. And
again, we've been talking about Satan uh
much and we can we can see that from
Satan's lies. They always have an
element of the truth, but then there's
always that did God really say that
twisting of the truth. So, one of the
things that that I would recognize from
what uh I'm trying to find a little bit
of common ground there um from what the
uh the clip showed is that God does use
means to accomplish his ends. So, when
we look to the commission of the church,
there there's a glorious part of this
task that God's people are called to
wherein uh Christ is accomplishing
victory through his church. We are
called his body. We we are given a task
in this world. We are uh imbued with his
spirit. Um so there there is a sense in
which um Christ accomplishes victory
through his church. And again I'm saying
that very generally um but trying to
find some of the common ground there
from which this uh this man was
operating in that clip. But one of the
one of the problems with what he
presented is um is a redefinition of
many terms. So he mentioned the gospel
and he said this great work the whole of
the gospel is for God to separate sin
from sinner. It's it's it's near to the
truth. But the the glorious truth of the
gospel is that the gospel is something
that is not us. It is not our work. It's
not the the work of human hands. The
gospel is the description of what God
has accomplished in the person and work
of Jesus Christ. We are the recipients
of the gospel as Christians. And for
that we praise God to the end of our
days and beyond. But Christ is the one
who has accomplished the gospel. The
gospel is about who Jesus is and what he
has done in his death, burial, and
resurrection. This is why when Paul
gives that glorious recap of the gospel
in 1 Corinthians 15, he says very little
about our task in this world that he
says much about the person and work of
Christ through whom we have life and
victory. Uh the gospel is simply not
about us. We are the recipients and
beneficiaries of the gospel. We live
because of the gospel. But but the
gospel is ultimately something about
Christ. So that's that's a very
unfortunate redefinition of that term.
Um, another redefinition uh which we
heard in that clip was just God's
sovereignty. Um, it's it's always
interesting to me when people define uh
sovereignty different than how scripture
defines sovereignty. Sovereignty being
the fact that God uh as we're told in
the Psalms is in the heavens and he does
all that he pleases. That means
everywhere at all times and in all
things. Um Isaiah speaks much of this.
Uh Isaiah 40-48 uh speaks much of this
that God does everything that he pleases
and everything that is within his will
and purview. One of the ways that I've
grown accustomed to defining sovereignty
is that God has a plan or decree um and
that he accomplishes that decree in all
things that he does so devoid of human
influences or outside influences. In
other words, there's nothing that can
stem or block or derail God's plan. God
is sovereign. For God to be dependent on
anyone is simply a redefinition of
sovereignty. Sovereignty no longer means
sovereign. I am not sovereign. I am I am
dependent on God for all things. Uh God
is not dependent on on me nor anyone
else for anything. And if he was, that
sovereignty would would be sacrificed
because to be sovereign is to be
independent and and fully in control. As
the psalmist said, God does all that he
pleases um in in the heavens and on
earth. So, it's it's an interesting it's
an interesting redefinition to somehow
paint man into the center of something
that God says that he has accomplished
in Jesus Christ. One of the one of the
glorious drum beats of the New Testament
is that Christ has accomplished
something perfectly and completely. This
is this is tantamount to the whole
message of the book of of the Hebrews uh
or the book to the Hebrews where
somebody that sounds a whole lot like
Paul um spent a whole lot of time
talking about the fact that Christ is
our great and final high priest. not
just the great high priest but the final
high priest. He is the the great and
final temple. He is the new and better
Adam. He is all these things completed
in his work. So it's it's very
unfortunate to take that and then then
to reframe it as we saw in that clip
that you played. Yeah. And so you're
kind of getting a glimpse there of how a
lot of Christianes is used, but it's
being defined by the great controversy
theme. So, when they hear you say, and I
guess I should say not all Adventists,
but the the run-of-the-mill individual
is going to hear you talk about victory
or those sorts of things, and they're
going to read into that because they've
been taught sinless perfectionism.
That's what real victory is. And that um
the gospel is really about this good
news that you can keep the law and that
Jesus gave you a second probation. All
of these details, folks, are coming from
the great controversy theme and being
brought to the Bible because the Bible
doesn't say these things. The Bible
doesn't say what Dwayne Lemon was just
putting forth there. He used a lot of
Christian ease, but that's not what the
Bible actually teaches. So, it even goes
beyond maneping the law perfectly,
though. And we talked about this a
little bit earlier, and we're going to
get back into it again just because it's
such a central component to this. But it
also uh speaks into their future
esqueological projections. One of which
that you mentioned, Revelation 20, is
that it plainly teaches that Satan will
be bound for a thousand years on the
earth. So, let me fill in some details
or put some skin on the bones. I haven't
gone um or rather explained the the SDA
system around the binding of Satan. When
the second coming happens, the
brightness will kill everyone who isn't
ready for translation. So those found
worthy will be resurrected. The
resurrection of the righteous, the first
resurrection, and then they'll and those
who are alive that are are righteous
will be translated and them along with
the resurrected righteous will be taken
to heaven for a thousand years. That's
where the millennial reign will happen
for a thousand years. a literal 10,00
years but in heaven. They then call this
the millennial reign judgment. So we
talked about this a little bit when I
was on your podcast. Their three-fold
division of judgment. So you have the
investigative pre-advent judgment which
is happening now. Then you'll have the
millennial reign judgment. This
millennial reign judgment will be where
they're essentially looking over God's
work in the investigative judgment to
see that God is actually fair and just
in what he's about to do regarding the
executive judgment. So they'll often
times use analogies like well someone
may get there and be like well why isn't
grandma here? I thought grandma was a
Christian. And God will open the books
for all of them to see. Well, see,
here's, you know, grandma had all these
sins that weren't confessed to Jesus to
deal with in the investigative judgment
and be covered. And that will cause them
to go, "Oh, okay. Well, then, you know,
God is fair and God is just." So, after
a thousand years of doing that and
looking over the books, God will then
pour out the executive judgment which
will be poured on Satan and the wicked.
But you mentioned this earlier, the
binding of Satan. What is it
specifically referring to in Revelation
20? Yeah. So the Revelation 20 is such a
is such a uh challenging passage, right?
Christians Christians have long long
found things that are challenging about
this. But Revelation 20:1, he says, John
says, "Then I saw an angel coming down
from heaven holding in his hand the key
to the bottomless pit and a great chain.
and he seized the dragon, that ancient
serpent who is the devil and Satan and
bound him for a thousand years. If I can
just pause there for a minute, this is
one of the ways that we uh we can fill
in a lot of the blanks or or tie a lot
of the uh uh tie a lot of the references
to Satan together because between
Revelation 12 and Revelation 20, we get
these sort of descriptions where it
where it lumps Satan together as devil
and Satan and dragon and serpent. That
ancient serpent referring back there to
Genesis chapter 3. But continuing in
Revelation 20, it says, "And threw him
into the pit and shut it and sealed it
over him so that he might not not
deceive the nations any longer until the
thousand years were ended. After that,
he must be released for a little while."
So the whole question is, what is this
binding of Satan? And how are we to
understand it? I've I've heard some
commentators say that this refers to a
complete sessation of all of all
activity, of all power, of all
influence, that if Satan is thrown into
a pit that he must be restrained from
any sort of activity or influence. But
that's just simply not what the passage
says. Um the passage does not say that
Satan is unable to send his minions out
into this world. It doesn't say that he
is unable to exert influence in some
regard. But what it does say is he is
specifically bound so that he might not
deceive the nations. That is the
qualifying phrase for what his binding
means. So if we were just to read
Revelation 20 with no other insight, we
would have to say, "I know what this
binding of Satan is because it tells me
he is bound that he might not deceive
the nations." When we tie that together
then with the rest of the testimony of
scripture and we look at what Christ is
describing in in his binding of Satan in
his earthly work, we see that as one and
the same. In fact, as I've referred to
earlier, the same phrases and the same
verbs are even used. So, in my humble
opinion, I think that this is not only
showing us the nature and the nature of
Satan's binding, but also the timing of
Satan's binding. It's the same binding
that Christ described in his earthly
work. And it's for a specific purpose,
not for the cessation of all activity or
influence, but specifically that he
might not deceive the nations until such
time as he was released. So with that in
mind, their system continues that after
the millennial reign, they teach that
there will be a second resurrection, the
resurrection of the wicked, where Satan,
after having been bound on the earth
alone for a thousand years, will have
one final harrah with the wicked, where
they'll be raised and they'll all rally
together with Satan to try and storm the
new Jerusalem that descends. It is at
this point that the whole earth will
have fire poured out on it and the
wicked will be burned up. Notice what
Ellen White says regarding this. She
writes, "The wicked receive their
recompense in the earth." Proverbs
11:31. "They shall be stubble, and the
day that cometh shall burn them up,
sayeth the Lord of hosts." Malachi 4:1.
"Some are destroyed as in a moment,
while others suffer many days. All are
punished according to their deeds. The
sins of the righteous having been
transferred to Satan, he is made to
suffer not only for his own rebellion,
but for all the sins which he has caused
God's people to commit. His punishment
is to be far greater than than that of
those whom he has deceived. After all
have perished who fell by his
deceptions, he is still to live and
suffer on. In the cleansing flames, the
wicked are at last destroyed. root and
branch. Satan the root, his followers
the branches. The full penalty of the
law has been visited. The demands of
justice have been met. And heaven and
earth beholding declare the
righteousness of Jehovah. So when fire
is poured out in the executive judgment,
Satan will be bearing the sins of those
found worthy of being saved and will pay
the ultimate penalty for them in the
lake of fire, which will be this earth.
Some people will burn longer than
others, but will eventually go out and
be annihilated. But Satan will suffer on
longer than any of the wicked. That is
what ultimately will bring about the
defeat of Satan. His blotting out of
existence, bearing the sins of the saved
as the antityypical day of atonement
scapegoat. Josh, does the Bible teach
that Satan bears the sins of believers
at any point? No. And I I don't even
know what more to say on that, honestly.
That's that's so troubling. Um the fact
that Satan would bear our sins in any
regard um is is horribly offensive. And
not to mention it's tragic. Uh it's
tragic to deceive anyone um who could
look to scripture and hear the words of
our Lord and Savior saying it is
finished to to Telsty on the cross
having borne the punishment for our sin
debt. Uh for those who would believe in
his name. What a what a travesty of
scripture to ascribe that not to Christ
but to the evil one. That that that
that's horrifying. And no, that's not
taught anywhere in scripture. What we do
find again just looking back to the to
the Revelation in chapter 20, uh we do
hear what happens um as as much as we
might grapple over the language and the
timing and I'm I'm sympathetic to those
battles. And yet we're told that when
the the thousand years are ended, Satan
comes out, he deceives the nations from
the four corners of the earth and he is
in summary fashion defeated by Christ.
this is um and thrown into the lake of
of fire and sulfur forever. Um it's it's
a it's a quite sumitive defeat. We're
not told exactly what percentage uh
arise in this. Sometimes has been
referred to as a great apostasy. Um I'm
sympathetic to that language, but um at
the same time it's it's a very summitive
defeat. But as far as Satan bearing the
sins um of those who are saved,
absolutely not. And in fact, scripture
clearly teaches that Christ is the sin
bearer um who who takes our sins on our
behalf. Yeah. So, this gets into their
whole, like I said, their their whole
system here of the sanctuary and this
model that kind of like she alluded to
earlier when she said that no sins were
canceled at the cross. Um, she makes a
pretty big blunder there because they
claim there what what would you what you
would call like a a theory if you will
um around transference and that blood
functions as a transference mechanism to
move sin around. That's a very regular
uh picture or image that is painted and
taught to 7th Day Adventists. And so
they'll point to the Old Testament uh
Levitical priest work, the daily
administration work, and they'll say in
type the the individual would show up
with their sacrifice for their sin. They
would lay their hand upon the sacrifice
that's going to be uh you know paying
the penalty for their sin and in type
their sin would be transferred to that
animal who bears the penalty. And then
the priest would take that blood and
take it inside the holy place to
sprinkle it before the veil to rest
there until the day of atonement when
the cleansing of the sanctuary would
take place. Now the error with this is
that Leviticus 4 is clear. There's only
two instances in which the priest took
blood into the the uh holy place. And it
was when the priest sinned or when the
nation, the covenant people of God as a
community sinned in ignorance that was
done. But it was never done on a daily
basis for penitent Israelites who showed
up with their sacrifice to then transfer
their blood inside the sanctuary. Yet
that is entirely necessary for this
whole schema to work because that's what
they claim is happening now in the
antityypical day of atonement. You
confess your sins to Jesus who is in a
pre in a building in heaven functioning
like a Levitical ironic priest. Even
though they'll tell you he's after the
order of MelkiseDC, he's functioning in
in that like manner that you confess
your sin and then it's transferred to
heaven to this sanctuary building for
Jesus to investigate it and cover it in
the investigative judgment and deal with
it. And if a person makes it through the
investigative judgment and is found
worthy of Christ's atoning benefits,
they will then have their sins again
transferred from there onto Satan in
this antitypical ceremony that's going
to take place where Satan as the
scapegoat is going to bear the sins. So
in their minds, there is a lot of
confusion that is creeping in from all
corners and all sides that's painting
the picture that makes it really hard
for them to see how Christians hear this
and think, "Whoa, what in the world?
Satan bearing sins at all." And in their
minds, it makes sense with this whole
schema. But like you highlighted there,
um there's just so many problems with
this. It takes away from the work of
Christ, the work of expeation, which is
what the scapegoat functioned as, the
removal of sin. Um, and there's a number
of things that we could get into on on
that front, but brother point out it
again, you're you're you're the subject
matter expert on on SDA theology, but it
seems that it seems that the words of
Christ in the New Testament must be very
um I'm trying to say this gently, but it
must be very confusing because there
seems to be such finality, such
completeness uh that Christ uses to
describe his own work and also the that
the New Testament uses to reflect on
that work. I was just flipping to to one
passage, Hebrews chapter 7 and verse 26.
Um the author of Hebrews said this. He
said, "For it was indeed fitting that we
should have such a high priest,"
speaking of Christ, "holy, innocent,
unstained, separated from sinners and
exalted above the heavens," which that
covers some of what we were talking
about earlier. "He has no need like
those high priests to offer sacrifices
daily first for his own sins and then
for those of the people since he did
this once for all when he offered up
himself." It it's just such finality and
completeness. I just find anyway I I
find that immensely comforting from
Hebrews but also immensely concerning
with with what you've what you've laid
out. Well, the book of Hebrews has been
a thorn in their side uh since their
inception. Um they have some fancy ways
typically by proof texting to try and
deal with the book of Hebrews. They tend
to ignore entire chapters, not kind of
seeing the overarching theme of Christ
being better like you pointed out there.
um from the ascension to 1844, Christ
was not doing a parallel ministry to the
daily ministration of the Levitical
priests only in a building up in heaven
to then enter into the most holy place
to begin the day of atonement work in,
you know, 1844. Uh but all of that stuff
is is central. That's really the central
hinge for the SDA movement. If that
falls and nothing happened in 1844,
um it was a it was a farce. And the the
scholarship of the movement understands
that. But that's why they're going to
defend this so vehemantly because
ultimately Satan's role in that whole
schema um is just as foundational as
Jesus's role. Sadly, actually hold up
one other question for you Josh. What
are your thoughts on this quote? Said
the angel market's influence, the
controversy between Christ and Satan is
not yet ended. This entering in of Satan
through the sciences is well devised by
his satanic majesty and will eventually
root out of the minds of thousands true
faith in Christ being the Messiah, the
son of
God. I I am I'm shocked to hear satanic
and
majesty put together.
Um I'm I'm just shocked by that. When
when I hear majesty, especially in
biblical terms, I'm thinking, "Oh Lord,
our Lord, how majestic is your name in
all the earth, um to ascribe that to
ascribe that to Satan is is is a
horrific mangling of biblical language
that ought only to be ascribed to our
Lord and Savior." Brother, thank you for
being here. It's always a joy to talk
with you and may God bless your guys'
ministry. Let people know where they can
find more of your guys' content. Yeah.
Thanks. Thanks so much, brother. We're
we're grateful for you and and grateful
for I said content earlier which sounds
so so trendy. I'm grateful for the work
you're doing truly. Um but yeah, if
anybody wants to to follow us, uh I'm
I'm not particularly interesting, but we
do have a channel. We have multiple uh
multiple contributors to that. It's
esquetology matters. Um we we operate
from a broadly reformed perspective and
and really what we're looking at is uh
covenantal esquetology. So we have
contributions from from various streams
within esquetology, but we're trying to
uh not only make things a little less
confusing, but also where there are
substantive uh real differences to at
least make those positions clear enough
where people feel comfortable uh working
through scripture and seeing that beauty
that God has because one of the
convictions that we have, and I know
I've heard this from you as well, Miles,
is just that um God's word is not given
to us to confuse or to frighten. God has
a wonderful story of what he's done in
Christ and we want people to uh to to
see the beauty of that story and
ultimately to see the beauty of the
Savior. So, thanks for that. Amen. Like
I said, love what you guys are doing
over there and uh until next time.
Thanks again.
Holy Ghost apostate. Did he say that?
Come on, man.